another night of violence in what's
become in recent days the most frequent
point of friction in the occupied west
bank
israeli troops sealed off the village of
burka villages through rocks and burned
tires the military said shots were fired
in the area soldiers fired live
ammunition rubber-coated steel bullets
and tear gas into the crowd
by sunday quiet had returned but after
days of what people here call
unprecedented levels of attacks by
israeli settlers
local activist hani describes how on
thursday night settlers descended from
the nearby illegal outpost of hamesh
vandalizing a cemetery before moving on
to the village itself
homes were stoned with alerts going out
that dozens of settlers were attempting
to get into houses
arafat salah says this level of threat
against the village is something new
i've been sitting up till morning in
case they come back they're out of
control no government controls them no
army controls them they attack you
anywhere
earlier on thursday thousands of
settlers gathered in a mass rally at the
entrance to homesh to mark a week since
the killing of yehuda dementman he was
shot as he left the outpost in an attack
attributed to the palestinian islamic
jihad armed faction
on sunday soldiers continued to guard
the entrance israel was supposed to
withdrawn from here in a 2005
disengagement plan but a religious
seminary has operated with military
protection ever since
since the shooting settlers have
repeatedly fought with soldiers as
they've tried to erect new structures
within hamesh they're calling for the
outpost to be formalized once more the
military closures in recent days have
happened when there have been large
numbers of settlers threatening the
village but villagers we've spoken to
say that the soldiers are here to ensure
the safety of those settlers when it
comes to protecting burqa from attack
they say they're on their own
the shooting 10 days ago has led to
reprisal attacks across the west bank
but it's here in burka where the threat
has been most concentrated and most
constant
the village remains on alert harry
fawcett al jazeera in the occupied west
bank